LAUD HIS OWN DECISION TO
WITHDRAW FROM AFGHANISTAN WHERE
AS CNN'S NIC ROBERTSON REPORTS
THERE'S A NEW PUSH FOR TALIBAN
FIGHTERS TO CONTROL KABUL'S
BUSINESS DISTRICT.
>> Reporter: TALIBAN COMMANDER
HAQQANI IS ON A PUBLIC OFFENSIVE
WINNING HE HOPES IN THE HEARTS
AND MINDS IN THE KABUL POLICE
DISTRICT HE NOW RUNS.
HE DOESN'T CARRY A WEAPON, BUT
HIS BACKUP DOES.
TALIBAN FIGHTERS FRESH FROM THE
FRONT LINES, TOTING AMERICAN
WEAPONS WEARING U.S. COMBAT
GEAR.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT NEIGHBORHOODS IN
KABUL, ITS CIRCUIT COURT A
PRIORITY FOR THE TALIBAN.
WITH THE TALIBAN'S
WELL-JUSTIFIED REPUTATION FOR
BRUTALITY, IT SHOULD BE AN EASY
JOB FOR THE 17-YEAR VETERAN
HAKKANI TO GET CONTROL BUT IT'S
NOT.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO BE POLICING
THE STREETS RATHER THAN FIGHTING
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY?
HE SAYS HE'S HAPPY TO SERVE THE
NATION JUST AS BEFORE, TO BRING
SHARIA RELIGIOUS LAW TO THE
CITY, BUT THERE ARE LOTS OF
PEOPLE, A LOT OF CORRUPTION AND
A LOT OF THIEVING TO GET RID OF,
HE SAYS.
HAQQANI'S POSTING USED TO BE THE
CITY'S PLUM POLICE JOB.
LOTS OF MONEY, LOTS OF
SHAKEDOWNS.
YOU GET THE FEELING WALKING
ALONG HERE THAT PEOPLE ARE STILL
BEING A LITTLE BIT CAUTIOUS
ABOUT THE TALIBAN, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THEY ARE OUT ON THE
STREETS.
THEY ARE TRAINING AND DOING
BUSINESS, SO IT FEELS LIKE IT'S
SETTLING DOWN, BUT IT'S THAT
KIND OF UNEASY FEELING WHICH WAY
IS IT GOING TO GO?
WE ARE HAPPY, THIS GOLD TRADER
TELLS ME.
NO CORRUPTION SO FAR.
I CAN LEAVE WORK AFTER DARK.
IT'S SAFER.
SO HOW IS THE SITUATION HERE
NOW?
>> THE SITUATION IS VERY GOOD.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU SEE LIKE ONE
YEAR AGO, TWO YEARS AGO WE SEE
THIEVES AND ROBBERY HERE AND NO
SECURITY HERE HAND NOW WITH
TALIBAN I HOPE AT TWILIGHT IT'S
VERY, VERY GOOD.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU SURE?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: WITH THE TALIBAN
WITHIN EAR SHOT IT'S HARD TO
KNOW FOR SURE HOW PEOPLE REALLY
FEEL, BUT DESPITE THEIR PRESENCE
SEVERAL BRAVE WOMEN APPROACH US.
THIS WOMAN CLOSE TO TEARS TELLS
ME SHE IS A WIDOW WITH SIX
CHILDREN.
THE TALIBAN FIRED HER FROM HER
GOVERNMENT JOB, SENT HER HOME
WITHOUT PAY.
AS WE TALK, ANOTHER WOMAN COMES
FORWARD.
ALSO OUT OF WORK, SHE SAYS,
BECAUSE THE TALIBAN STOPPED
GIRLS SHE TAUGHT FROM GOING TO
SCHOOL.
SHE'S BEEN PAID FOR NEXT MONTH
BUT HAS NO IDEA WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT.
IT'S UP TO HAQQANI TO CHOOSE
WHETHER HE'LL BE FIRM AND
RESPECTED OR FORCEFUL AND FEARED
LIKE THE TALIBAN BEFORE.
WHICH WAY HE'LL TIP A BELLWETHER
FOR THE COUNTRY.
I ASKED HIM THAT VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION WHAT IS HE DOING WITH
HIS THIEVES?
IS HE CUTTING THEIR HANDS OFF
THE SAME WAY THAT THE TALIBAN
USED TO DO?
HE TOLD ME NO,